[Music]
straight ahead
all law and crime daily prosecutors work
to build a murder case after an officer
dies from injuries during the storming
of the u.s capitol building they fought
they fought very hard
a breakdown of the arrests already made
and the suspects investigators are still
searching for
the woman wanted for assaulting a teen
after wrongly accusing him of stealing
her phone
is finally caught how police tracked her
down across the country
no he's not leaving show me the proof
plus an update in the dd blanchard case
why gypsy's former boyfriend is asking a
judge to set aside his conviction
and arguments continue for the so-called
doomsday cult couple
should lori valo and chad dave bell's
prosecutor be removed law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin
federal authorities are opening a murder
investigation into the death of a
capitol police officer
after the attempted insurrection
authorities say u.s capitol police
officer brian siknik died thursday night
of injuries sustained on duty
when a mob stormed the capitol building
he was snatched into a crowd
he was beaten he was kicked he was tased
several times according to capitol
police officials sic nick collapsed
after returning to his division and
later died in a hospital
his death is being investigated by
federal authorities as well as the d.c
metropolitan police department
more than 50 officers were also injured
there was a lot of valiant fighting by
the members of the metropolitan police
department
there at one point several officers
as a result of munitions and kept and
pepper spray and tear gas
being able to step off the line be
triaged quickly and back on the line
to try to ensure the safety and security
of our
capital building multiple agencies are
working to identify people involved in
the riot
the fbi is offering a 50 000 reward for
information leading to the arrest
and conviction of the suspects seen here
believed to have planted pipe bombs
at the republican and democratic
national committee headquarters
and d.c police have released this
27-page document
containing persons of interest wanted
for capital insurrection
we have authorized a reward of up to one
thousand dollars for information that
leads to the rest and conviction of
persons responsible
and i should add that we already are
receiving information
and tips and valuable tips in from
residents and people who
who have identified some of these
individuals
d.c police say they received nearly 20
000 tips
which have already led to the capture
and arrest of suspects
richard barnett is accused of breaking
into speaker nancy pelosi's office
placing his feet on her desk and
stealing a letter barnett was arrested
in little rock arkansas
he's facing charges of entering and
remaining on restricted grounds
violent entry and theft of public
property other people now charged
include a man
accused of bringing molotov cocktails to
d.c
and a west virginia representative who
filmed himself storming the building
officials say they're far from done
making arrests
the chaos at the capitol has raised a
lot of questions about what federal
charges people involved
could face law and crimes angenette levy
spoke with a former federal prosecutor
about sedition and more yeah that's
right
brian current and former u.s attorneys
say that there are really a laundry list
of charges that could apply in this case
and the u.s attorney overseeing district
the district of columbia says one of
those charges includes sedition
now there are a bunch of other charges
on the list as well
including civil disorder which includes
any activity that keeps law enforcement
from performing its duties
that can carry five years in prison the
federal riot act applies to anyone who
traveled interstate to incite a riot
that also carries a possible five-year
prison sentence
and rebellion and insurrection that
includes inciting or engaging in
rebellion against the united states
that can carry a maximum 10 years in
prison
those charges are all part of a u.s code
entitled treason
sedition and subversive activities
i think there's a lot of statutes that
are potentially applicable here
um ranging from relatively minor
like trespass all the way to charges
like murder that are death eligible from
what i've seen publicly reported there
is
a strong basis in my opinion to
investigate potentially prosecute
people for seditious conspiracy i mean
that charge which is 18
us code section 2384
requires you to requires two or more
people to
join a conspiracy which just means to
agree
to overthrow the government of the
united states by
force
and then glassman says that seditious
conspiracy charge is actually a little
more broad and it can
include trying to prevent a law from
actually being carried out
and that carries a hefty penalty a
maximum of
20 years in federal prison brian
thanks angenet joining us now for a
deeper dive into the legal matters is
criminal defense attorney julie
rendellman along with terry austin of
course angelette levy
juliet you're a former prosecutor and
you've been a defense attorney for some
of these new york protests as well
what is the prosecution of these cases
with the 20 000 tips coming in
going to look like so you know keep in
mind most of these are
we're dealing with federal charges and i
can promise you that the fed
federal investigators investigating this
are going to you know turn over
every single rock that's possible in
terms of trying to determine
who is particularly responsible for each
act but even more importantly the death
of this police
officer and so you know what they're
going to be doing is they're not just
going through the tips they're going to
be going through video footage
every single bit of video footage
beginning during and after to see if
they can find
anyone surrounding this individual i
think one of the other big issues that's
going to come up
is an autopsy they're going to want to
know exactly what the cause of death is
for this police officer
because as we know we know he was beaten
we don't know exactly what happened
but we know that when he returned to his
command he collapsed so the autopsy is
going to be another big issue that
they're going to be investigating it's
going to take them
a lot of time and manpower but at the
end of the day i'm confident
that someone or more than one person is
going to be held
responsible not just for the death of
this police officer
but for other actions in regards to what
happened at the capitol
now terry death of an officer is one
thing but death of an officer defending
the united states capital
could there be heftier penalties for
those accused of this crime
well you know brian it does depend on
whether it's under local d.c
law or whether it's federal law the
penalties are very similar but they're
not identical under d.c law assault
carries 10 years
under federal law it would be 30 years
and if someone who might have killed
the officer involved that would carry a
penalty under d.c law
of life in prison but if it's under
federal law that could be death or life
in prison so they're very similar but
they aren't identical
gotcha now angenette what's the status
of the people who have been arrested so
far
you know brian more than 80 people have
been arrested by federal police and d.c
police more arrests are expected as more
tips come in
and dozens of those people have already
had their initial court appearances
they were released afterwards and the
judge has ordered them not to return to
the dc
area until their next court appearances
in june
all right thank you all for your input
still ahead on law and crime
daily why a man convicted of stabbing
his girlfriend's mother to death
is asking the judge to set aside his
criminal case
but first police catch the woman seen on
video falsely accusing a teen of
stealing her phone
we look into her lengthy criminal
background next
the question of whether the trial of the
former officers involved in the death of
george floyd will be delayed remains
unsolved
attorneys for the ex-cops including
derrick shoven appeared in a remote
hearing in minneapolis
the trial is set to begin march 8 but
attorneys for
chauvin and tu tau are asking it to be
delayed until july
citing concerns over the coronavirus an
attorney for thomas lane told the judge
it should remain in march
saying the colder weather might limit
public reaction prosecutors asked for it
to begin in june
floyd was killed last may after officers
kneeled on his neck
for more than eight minutes the judge is
expected to rule at a later date
a woman charged with wrongfully accusing
a black teenager of stealing her phone
in a hotel lobby has now been arrested
22 year old maya poncetto was captured
near her home in ventura county
california the local sheriff's office
says ponsento was uncooperative
resisted arrest and tried to slam the
door of her car on one of the deputies
as they forcibly removed her
the arrest was in coordination with the
new york city police department
the boy's father grammy-winning jazz
musician kenyon herald recorded the
incident in the arlo hotel
on his cell phone
this is my phone no you don't have to
explain that to her
that's fine are you kidding me you feel
like there's only one
one iphone made in the world no okay
then show me this no you
get a life over there you better go use
fine
find my iphone don't do that find my
iphone is off
no no you can't no i'm the manager of
no
no i'm not letting him walk away with my
phone please get my phone back i can't
wait i cannot have myself
back with me is julie rendellman and
terry austin julie poncetto is on
three-year probation in l.a county
her arrest sounds like there could be
criminal charge there as well what do
you think of her criminal cases will
look like
in the next couple months i find myself
shaking my head every time i see
this video and so look she has three
years probation if she violates
probation
in california she can be looking at jail
for that case
now we tack on the fact that when she
got arrested for the case in new york
she apparently assaulted the police
officers and resisted the rest there
now we have another charge or several
charges there that could
potentially have her facing jail time as
well
and we don't know the specifics of the
new york charges but we certainly know
there
there are near charges there are likely
felony if there's extradition
and so now she's not just facing the two
different counties in california
but she's coming back to new york and
she's gonna have to face those as well
where she also is potentially facing
a felony and jail time exactly now terry
like uh julie said we don't know the
charges in new york is yet but she is
being extradited it appears she has
cases from coast to coast
what's that new york city case going to
look like and what potential charges
could you face
you know i think the fact that we have
video is definitely going to assist with
the prosecution of whatever
ultimate charges we have against poncero
and
you know a spokesman for the manhattan
d.a said that they were thoroughly
investigating the incident and what i'm
thinking is that they're going to be
criminal charges for assault in new york
there is no criminal charge for
battery but they have enough to say that
she
intentionally struck someone and she
caused injury
we saw the picture of the injury so i
think we'll see that
yeah there's also potential for
attempted robbery charges that she
injured someone in the attempt to try to
take someone's cell phone that wasn't
hers well of course keep an update on
that
coming up on law and crime daily
arguments over possibly removing the
prosecutor of the so-called doomsday
cult duo continued
plus remember the case of a mother
accused of forcing her daughter to be
wheelchair-bound and hospitalized
well we've got an update to the status
of her convicted killer you don't want
to miss
after the break
attorneys for the man serving like a
life sentence for the murder of
dede blanchard are seeking
post-conviction relief
nicholas godijon was convicted of
brutally stabbing to death the mother of
his girlfriend gypsy blanchard
didi blanchard apparently suffered from
munchausen by proxy and forced gypsy to
be in a wheelchair
claiming her daughter had cancer and
other illnesses to get money for charity
a psychologist who interviewed gotechia
and told the law and crime network that
go to john
does suffer from mental illness but has
full reasoning and judgment skills
the term mental capacity whether or not
he
lacked that um that's a really good
question
and um it's a bit of a difficult phrase
because
it's really better to say you know did
he have diminished
uh mental capacity as opposed to
completely lacking it
and that was the problem in his
situation because
the the key issue is that he needed to
have
intent to do the crime and in missouri
you know there's three different aspects
and
the issue that was most uh relevant was
the issue of
deliberation did he have cool reflection
upon the matter for any length of time
no matter how short
and so in that regard uh nicholas
uh did have the ability to form
intent and so the notion of
diminished capacity well he in in that
regard he would not have met
or and did not meet the legal criteria
for diminished capacity
even though he did have a genuine mental
health concern
julie you followed this case what do you
make of the arguments made for go to
john do you see
other potential better arguments or is
this the best one they've got so far
so you know keep in mind a
post-conviction relief
when you try to seek that it usually
means that you've used up
all of your other appeals and so you're
kind of boiled down to very little
and usually the road that they follow is
where
they accuse their attorney of doing
something wrong we haven't seen the
exact nature of what it's going to be in
this case
but i'm guessing that's the road they're
going to take that somehow there was
some
incompetence on the part of the attorney
now it might relate
to the intellect or competence of this
defendant i'm not
sure but i don't think they're going to
be successful at the end as they haven't
been
uh prior to this all right so tara weigh
in on the success here
it is as julie said a very narrow
argument
do you think the defense will be
successful here i don't i agree
wholeheartedly with julie here i think
it's
very difficult to get post-conviction
relief i mean if you think about it
every convicted person would be trying
to do this they are
very limited grounds you know it would
have to be something as serious as
the trial court had no jurisdiction or
that the sentence exceeded
the maximum possible sentence or that
there was some violation of
constitutional or state law
i don't think that we have any of those
things here i think the claim
about the mental you know incapacity is
really not going to prevail here that's
something they could have argued early
on
and so i think it's going to fail here
yeah and terry the list you gave us is
actually the
i think the statutory list of what they
can do because this
as uh julie said it's very different
than a typical appeal it's a last straw
you've got a couple swings at this uh
this
this tree to kind of knock down the
appeal i agree with you both i don't see
it here but you've got to shoot your
shot
thank you both when we come back why the
mother accused of covering up her
children's death
thinks she's being unfairly prosecuted
an inside look into the lorry vallo case
continuing coverage for a hearing for
the so-called doomsday cult couple
trying to disqualify their prosecutor
terry ozil has been following this case
closely and is here to break down the
legal arguments
brian it's a case that's making national
headlines not only because of how
bizarre it is but because
there are so many unanswered questions
lori vallo and her husband chad daibel
are facing charges of conspiring to
conceal and destroy
evidence in the deaths of valo's two
children
the bodies of jj and tyler ryan were
discovered
buried in a shallow grave on day bells
idaho property
they're not charged with murder but the
prosecutor was heard during a secretly
recorded meeting
with valo's sister saying he plans to
file conspiracy
to commit murder charges the defense now
wants
prosecutor rob wood removed and hired a
law professor at the university of idaho
who says woods actions are concerning
is that i feel like the prosecutor is
giving a narrative
to the witness incentivizing the witness
to tell a specific story
and providing her with you know a little
bit of
you know um subtle pressure that would
encourage her i think to give a story
that would
uh coincide with the state's theory of
the case so you can't say
to a specificity whether this was
witness uh influence or whether it was
not you can't say to a certainty is that
fair
i think i can say it's coaching clearly
under just what the established
guidelines are which is
which is not necessarily prohibited you
can
you can coach a witness you can that we
to some degree the law encourages
lawyers to sit down with the witness and
work with them before they testify
what where it's improper is undo and
what i
can't say is whether this witness felt
pressure
to change her story which is where this
would become ethically problematic
uncross an attorney for prosecutor rob
wood asked
if the witness was coached what's the
remedy
i would think it would be in the court's
prerogative to determine the best
approach but i don't think it's
unreasonable for the court to bring in
the witness
and ask her you recall this conversation
with the prosecutor um did it
influence your testimony in any way you
know did it
cause you to change um your opinion
about what you wanted to you know did
you feel pressured to implicate chad
dabo
did you feel pressure to try to get your
sister
off if the witness is saying yes i did
well you know then i think the questions
would be well then
in what ways did you change your
statements to the police
and if she did i mean those can be
corrected in advance of trial right if
the witness is willing to take the oath
and testify truthfully in front of a
jury then i don't see how there would be
a problem at trial
julie as a former prosecutor you've
interviewed probably hundreds if not
thousands of witnesses
in your eyes did wood do something wrong
here
yeah no um do i love everything he said
no
did i find everything he said to be of
the utmost professional no i don't think
talking about someone as a wimp or that
they peed their pants
uh or would have is appropriate but do i
think that it rose to the level of
causing him to
have to be removed from this case
absolutely not
the witness could be cross-examined for
anything that they feel
may have hindered or impacted her
ability to give
honest testimony now terry you've given
your opinion on this in the past but
you've also been following it day by day
have any of these arguments swayed you
or solidified your opinion in any way
once again i do not think that this has
reached the level of prosecutorial
misconduct i agree 100 with julie again
and
this witness samuel newton i mean he was
a criminal law professor
he gave a lot of opinions regarding that
this came close
to the line of misconduct or maybe close
to the line of being unethical or maybe
close to the line of even
being criminal but he said it didn't
cross in his opinion
and the whole question is whether or not
summer
was influenced in terms of changing her
testimony
and right now we don't have that and in
fact he said he couldn't say
what her thoughts might be later down
the line and he couldn't say
what rob wood's intention was so i think
at the end of the day
rob wood is going to stay on this case
and he's not going to be dismissed
yeah it's very interesting to see how
this played out i saw a lot of the
evidence or evidence coming in as being
as a potential but not necessarily right
to that level
julian terry thank you for joining us
and thank you for joining us here at
long crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you